[Musique]
à l'Ontario les électeurs de la province
vont élire leur nouveau conseil
municipaux demain il y a plus de 400
municipalités de la province qui vont
choisir leur mère et leur conseille
municipaux sur une campagne qui n'a pas
sauvé les passions partout de la même
façon c'est le cas entre autres à
Toronto je rejoins ma collègue julienne
lamoureuse qui est devant l'hôtel de
ville de Toronto justement Julian c'est
une campagne pas mal tranquille qui se
termine dans la ville
absolument Daniel écouter c'est la
troisième campagne électorale en quoi à
peu près un an là il y a eu les
fédérales l'année dernière en juin
dernier c'est les élections provinciales
donc il est possible qu'il y a un
désintérêt de la part de certains
électeurs mais quand même quand on se
promenait dans certains quartiers de la
ville il y a des endroits où il y avait
très peu ou à peu près pas de pancartes
il y a eu aussi deux débats seulement
avec les principaux candidats à la
mairie on a connu des années beaucoup
plus mouvementées beaucoup plus agitée
où il y avait beaucoup plus de débats
donc on a l'impression que la campagne
électorale c'est un peu déroulé en toile
de fond et pourtant il y a une trentaine
de candidats trentaine de personnes qui
se présentent à la mairie de Toronto
dont le plus connu John Tory le maire
sortant qui sollicite un troisième
mandat c'est lui qui a géré la pandémie
donc une figure très importante que les
gens connaissent bien et ils subit il a
subi au cours des dernières semaines
toutes les attaques il est toutes les
attaques ont été dirigées contre lui de
la part de des candidats qui se
présentent notamment guilde penalossa
qui sont principales adversaire c'est un
urbaniste bien connu à travers le monde
et à travailler sur tous les continents
dans plus de 300 villes et ils pensent
être une meilleure personne un meilleur
maire pour diriger Toronto alors on
verra les sondages donne l'avance à
Monsieur tourry et s'il l'emporte demain
il deviendrait au terme de ce troisième
mandat le maire de Toronto ayant siéger
le plus longtemps il aurait siéger donc
12 ans Julien dans Ottawa c'est une
autre histoire Jim Watson ne se
représente pas près 12 ans à la taille
de la ville ça change la donne un peu
pour la course
ça donne une course plus emballante plus
excitante peut-être parce qu'un suspense
demain soir il y aura nécessairement une
nouvelle personne assise dans le siège
du maire d'Ottawa donc il y a du
suspense là on sait qu'il y a deux
candidats qui ressortent du lot sur les
14 qui se présentent
marxing qui pourrait donc diriger la
Ville d'Ottawa à partir de demain et à
Ottawa comme ailleurs dans la province
parmi les thèmes qui sont ressortis dans
cette campagne électorale il y a le
logement le logement le logement aussi
le transport en commun évidemment le
coût de la vie là qui touche tout le
monde
conversation il y a des élections dans
400 municipalités Ontario vous
surveillez quoi vous spécifiquement
autre Toronto et Ottawa demain il y a la
ville de Brampton Daniel qu'il faut
surveiller demain ou le maire sortant
patrick Brown sollicite un deuxième
mandat patrick Brown vous le connaissez
c'est le candidat à la direction du
Parti conservateur du Canada qui a été
exclu cette année il était en très forte
avance dans les sondages cet été pour
remporter un second mandat à la mairie
de primton mais c'était Carla c'est à
menuiser au cours des dernières semaines
sa principale rivale Nikki coeur une
gestionnaire municipale fait campagne en
l'accusant de manquer des tiques et elle
est appuyer par une équipe solide de
stratège des gens qui ont fait élire
robford ici à Toronto John Tory
également et qui en ont gros contre
Patrick donc ce sera à surveiller demain
soir et ça montre aussi que après la vie
en politique provinciale il y a une vie
en politique municipale parce que
Monsieur Brown c'est un ancien chef du
Parti progressiste conservateur de
l'Ontario qui est ensuite allié aux
municipales et là demain à hamleton il y
a l'ancienne chef John [ __ ] Andrea Orval
qui se présente comme mère est de
Hamilton après sa défaite de juin
dernier elle avait perdu son siège même
chose pour l'ancien chef du Parti
libéral de l'Ontario Steven del douka
qui a eu une qui a subi une cuisante
défaite en juin dernier il tente sa
chance comme mère devant Leila de de
l'emporter donc ce seront des luttes
qu'on va surveiller demain à noter
Daniel cette année 31% des candidats qui
se présentent sont des femmes c'est loin
des 50% qui réclame bien des gens mais
quand même c'est mieux que les 27 % d'il
y a 4 ans petit à petit en fait des
problèmes amoureux à Toronto merci
beaucoup
je vous en prie